all right in today's money watch we're
talking about taxes as filing season
gets underway today is the first day
americans can file their taxes for 2021.
now the irs has already said that there
will be challenges due to significant
backlog of returns from last year as of
december there are still six million
individual returns remaining cbs news
business analyst jill schlesinger joins
us dolla dolla jill y'all so what's up
let's talk these taxes okay so irs said
that it's going to be challenging but
what does that mean for taxpayers well
after two years where we had delays in
tax filing we're back to the month of
april but even that's confusing it's
usually april 15th this year it's april
18th because we have an emancipation day
holiday in washington d.c if you live in
massachusetts and maine you get even
another day till the 19th because of
patriots day the confusing part is that
the irs is really under a lot of
pressure there aren't people to help you
out in fact the irs budget and the
staffing has been cut so dramatically by
17
by over the past dozen years and their
workload has increased by 19 so
confusing is essentially we are not
there to help you out use the website so
if people file and submit their taxes as
soon as possible how soon could they get
their return if they're eligible well
the irs says it should be 21 days
presuming that you've e-file very
important to e-file presuming that you
have direct deposit a lot of people
learn the wrong lesson out of the
coveter which is if you don't have
direct deposit you don't get your money
so fast so get that and also presuming
that you your math works meaning the irs
is sending a lot of notices out to
people they want you to make sure your
numbers jibe with their numbers speaking
of the kobe year there's people that are
waiting on their returns from last year
so what should they do should they wait
before they submit this year the irs
says absolutely not get boogieing and
here's why because you know even if you
didn't get your return if you e-file you
can still get this return done quickly
now here's one weird thing when you file
but the irs asks you in the ue file is
hey what was your adjusted gross income
last year well you didn't get your
return back yes so the irs says put a
zero there that's really important it
says little detail but you got to do it
do it early because the backlogs are
only going to increase are there
individuals that should wait to file
up until the
closer deadline to april well you know
look if you owe money i wouldn't rush to
file frankly so if you owe the irs money
you think you're going to owe then i'll
be filing on you know very late people
like you nate you know
all right so there are more than 36
million families that got half of their
child tax credit um so what do they need
to do to make sure they get the back end
well this is so strange because now
you've got to check your snail mail what
like yeah you got to go into your snail
mail you're getting a letter a love
letter from the irs right and the irs is
going to tell you here's how much money
you got from the child tax credit last
year here's what you're due this year
you have to file a return that letter
has a lot of important information for
you so i want to make sure that
everybody really takes a look at it now
if you didn't get the child tax credit
last year but you think you're owed it
that's okay you still have to file
that's true even if you're the type of
person who never filed a tax return so
you can go to the irs portal there's a
child tax credit portal check that out
all right so the government sent out um
two stimulus checks in 2021. are these
payments taxable they are not taxable
whoo that's great right so you get to
keep that money but a lot of people
maybe their income changed last year
maybe they took some time off so if you
think you're due the stimulus money and
you didn't get it you have to file for
the recovery rebate credit it's kind of
annoying it's line 30 on your 1040. why
do i know this i don't know
this is something you have to do to get
the money you're owed i got to ask you
this real quick because there's a lot of
viewers that are working from home can
you deduct the home supplies and things
within the house the answer is if you
are an employee you're out of luck
because employees are no longer allowed
to deduct any home business expenses
again your boss is may have sent you
something that's fine but you can't
deduct anything that's because of the
tax change in 2017. good news is if
you're a gig worker if you're a
part-timer if you're self-employed you
can deduct a lot and i encourage you to
do so the rules are on the irs website
really be careful though there are very
particular things that you need to be
watching for in terms of those
deductions you're the best let's talk
about tax baby let's talk about you and
me thank you so much